hey guys my name is Jess McDonald is a
16th of februari today and you're
watching games but news is not matter to
them Darksiders true the definitive
edition is a thing according to publish
and nordic games that's even though
original publisher THQ was dissolved two
years ago a ps4 listing for the game
popped up on Amazon that said the game
will run you 40 bucks before it was
quickly pulled down nonetheless Nordic
have said the listing was authentic and
while we aren't certain there will also
be an xbox one version of the definitive
edition it seems pretty likely Nordic
games who sent 4.9 million on a bunch of
THQ properties as they were auctioned
off I said they aren't prepared to
discuss the next-gen Darksiders to
further at this time now this next story
of making a lot of people mad for a lot
of different reasons so I'm just gonna
give you what we know so far and you can
make up your own mind there's been a lot
and I mean a lot of controversy
surrounding the length of the order 1886
there were rumors floating around that
the game might be three hours long then
developer ready at dawn said it's
certainly no less than five hours and
got sick of commenting on it there have
also been conflicting reports on near
gaps saying it might be more than 12
hours now the latest drama has come out
thanks to a YouTube channel called play
me through who posted a complete
playthrough of the game in just on five
hours it's being argued that this might
have been on easy mode a speedrun or
more of a casual than a completionist to
play through but it is another number to
throw in the already convoluted mix the
YouTube playthrough is miraculously
still up even though the game isn't out
yet so you can check it out for yourself
through our link on gamespot in news
that is almost as bad as Taylor Swift
trademarking the phrase of this thicker
beat apparently you can't with the would
fall out in your game name lest you
incur Bethesda's
indie studio x real had been making a
game called fortress fallout for several
months they were then sent a cease and
desist letter from Bethesda Softworks
who according to X real founder Howard
Marks is a notoriously litigious company
given Bethesda have a lot of money and X
real have not a lot of money the dev
have been forced to change the game's
name nice work Bethesda you took out the
little guy very impressive Bethesda were
previously engaged in a dispute with
minecraft creator mojang over the name
of their game Scrolls which Bethesda
said was also their word the YouTube
community has suggested fortress outfall
as a good alternative for marks game one
would hope that X real won't be hearing
from valve over a team fortress title
infringement issue next let me know down
in the comments if you reckon Bethesda
had the right to be the bad guy here and
how much you care about the length of a
game you can add two games but where
we've got stories on monster hunter
sales and halo nightfall that is it for
me today leave me your thoughts as
always and I'll be back same time
tomorrow with a bunch more news